-Olivia has a thing
for Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
-Yes, she does.
-There's a photo
in the back there.
I don't know
if people can see it.
This is an easier one to see
like, right at the desk.
-Yes.
-She's there.
-My son gave me this.
-He did?
-My son gave me that because -
-And that is something tha
then you decided to --
to add to the character?
-Well, as I became,
you know, lieutenant,
and I started thinking
about who do I look up to,
who do I -- who is
Olivia Benson's inspiration?
And she is about as superher
as they come.
-Yeah.
-And it makes --
and it really just --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I could -- Right?
I could just --
I watched that movie.
And it changed my life.
And I could watch that movie
on a loop, "RBG."
-That's great. And it's fu
to bring something persona
to a character that obviousl
you have a very personal
connection to.
We've talked
in the past about --
-So, would I ever say --
would never want to say,
"I can't."
I say, "Well, actually I can."
-That's nice.
-So, yeah.
-I'm thinking of getting -
I'm going to get Queen Dulcine
on my desk.
If I can find someone
to make me --
-I think it should be
a permanent fixture here.
-We've talked about Halloween.
-Yes.
-And your family. Do you guy
know where you're going?
'Cause tend to do
family costumes.
-We do. We do. Yes, we do.
This year, my two
8-year-olds picked it.
And we are going as
the Descendants.
-Okay.
-Disney Descendants.
Not -- Not
the George Clooney movie.
-I was gonna say.
That seems like --
-Nope, not that one.
-Yeah, just Hawaiian shirt
and flip-flops.
-Yeah. Right. Not happening.
So, I'm not -- I'm just
sort of signed up this yea
to play the part
that they want me to play.
And they're very excited
about it.
And we're good to go.
-That's great.
-I got a little pushback
from August, the 13-year-old
-What was the pushback?
-"I'm not being a Descendant."
-Oh, he does --
So, who's decided?
-The little ones.
-Gotcha.
-The two 8-year-olds. They sor
of called the shot this year
-I see that if you're
a 13-year-old,
you might not want your
public choices being made
by 8-year-olds.
-Right. So --
That's what he said.
But he has gone AWOL before.
There was the year that
he called, when he was 3,
"Mary Poppins."
So Peter and I went full,
you know,
Mary Poppins and Bert.
And then he goes -- He was 3
"Yeah, I think I'm gonna
do Spider-Man. Sorry."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-So you were full Poppins,
walking around
with a Spider-Man,
which then made it look like
you've lost your minds.
-Yep. A little bit.
-Yeah.
-A little bit.
And I was okay with it.
-Yeah, so he should -- he should
bite the bullet this time.
-Exactly.
But this year he's gonna be --
I think he's gonna go --
he's going as cool pirate.
-Cool pirate?
-Yeah.
-That is the most
13-year-old choice.
-Right?
-Yeah.
Yeah, no, I'm not, like,
gonna do, like, the parrot
I'm gonna do the eyepatch, yeah.
-Some leather pants,
and we're good.
-Always so great to see you.
-Thank you so much.
-Congratulations on 21 seasons
-Thank you.
-Oh, my gosh.
Mariska Hargitay, everybody.